and here's my story Clarence Moyer a
World War two veteran nicknamed the hero
of Cologne was surprised with a ceremony
yesterday in Washington to ward him an
overdue Bronze Star Medal with a V for
valor almost 75 years after he fought
the 96 year old tank gunner is the last
living member of his crew that destroyed
a powerful German panther tank in a
pivotal battle about nine months before
d-day he was credited with spearheading
the invasion this is actual footage from
that time that they took of that battle
it was such a big important battle there
he is on top of the tank that's Clarence
he's credited with destroying five tanks
in the war actually but he never got a
medal apparently he was written up for
fraternizing with the enemy when he
helps some German kids get home to their
mom and an MP saw it and and wrote him
up so an author named Adam Miko's
discovered this researching a book about
the battle and campaigned to make this
right and it finally happened yesterday
on the National Mall but it was a
beautiful picture of him standing there
so yeah he didn't know they told him
they were gonna take him for a you know
for a trip to the to see the Pentagon
and instead they diverted him here and
he got out of the car and he said am I
gonna get a bronze very very love it